Fluoridation is the act of adjusting fluoride
levels in water, with the goal of reducing
tooth decay.
In 1945, Grand Rapids, Michigan was the first
city in the world to do it.
In 1999, the CDC declared that water fluoridation
was one of the ten great public health achievements
of the 20th century.
However, a quick online search will yield
countless articles discounting these claims,
with the general consensus of the dissenters
being that fluoride is actually harmful to
one’s health.
So which is it?
Is fluoride good or bad for you?
To answer that, let’s take a closer look
at fluoride, what it does in the body, and
why governments of the world think it’s
so beneficial.
In the early part of twentieth century, Dr.
Frederick McKay noticed that his patients
in Colorado Springs had brown stains on their
teeth.
He, along with Dr. G.V.
Black, termed the condition as mottled enamel.
Now known as enamel fluorosis, they also found
those brown stains appeared to give people
a surprising resistance to tooth decay.
They hypothesized that something about the
drinking water was the cause.
In the 1930s, it was shown that fluoride was
the culprit giving the stains and the protection
against cavities.
Fluoride, in general, is a very common natural
compound.
Its base element is fluorine, the most electronegative
of all elements.
(In a nutshell, electronegative means it wants
electrons like a cat wants catnip.)
It’s found pretty much everywhere in nature,
including the food you eat, and, contrary
to what many people think, even in the untreated
water you drink.
Fluoride naturally attracts calcium, so in
the body it’s mainly associated with calcified
tissues, like bones and teeth.
Fluoride will combine with hydrogen to form
the acid hydrogen fluoride.
Most of the reactions, like it’s absorption
through the stomach, and the way kidneys clear
it from your system, is due to how hydrogen
fluoride reacts as it’s distributed throughout
the body.
For a healthy adult, about 50% of fluoride
consumed is retained by calcified tissues;
the other half is excreted in urine.
In children, as much as 80% is taken in by
calcified tissues.
This is because kid’s bodies are still growing
relatively rapidly.
Thus, fluoride will attract and help calcify
those developing teeth and bones.
The older you get, the less your body needs
per unit mass, so more fluoride is excreted
and less is retained.
So what is the recommended intake of fluoride?
That depends on your age.
Since almost all nutrients needed are based
on an amount proportional to your mass (in
this case measured in weight), the older you
get, the more per day you need.
For example, infants 0-6 months need about
.01 mg/day.
At 4-8 year of age you need about 1mg/day,
and at 9-13 need about 2mg/day.
Over the age of 19 and the amount is around
4mg/day for men and 3mg/day for women.
As previously mentioned, fluoride is found
almost everywhere, including your food.
For example, when you consume 100 grams of
table wine, you’ll also be naturally consuming
about 0.2 mg of fluoride; with 100 grams of
seedless raisins about 0.23 mg, the same amount
of brewed tea gives you 0.37 mg, and cooked
crustaceans, like crab and shrimp, 0.16 mg.
The question then becomes, if fluoride is
found in so many things, and we take it in
daily, why did they start adding it to water?
The answer is that studies showed that in
areas where water isn’t fluorinated, the
average dietary intake for adults was 0.3-1
mg per day- far less than the recommended
intake for optimal health for adults.
For areas where fluoride in the water was
1mg/liter, the average intake was 1.4-3.4
mg per day.
Just about the right amount an adult body
needs to fight off those expensive cavities,
among other benefits.
So how does fluoride help with tooth decay?
Cavities, known as dental caries, begin when
bacteria start propagating in the small cracks
and crevices of your teeth.
The plaque that naturally builds up contains
copious amounts of these microbes, such as
streptococcus mutans and Lactobacillus.
When the bacteria begin to consume carbohydrates,
mostly the high concentrations of sugar found
within the foods and drinks we consume, they
produce acids.
When those acids create a pH less than 5.5,
they will begin to dissolve your tooth enamel
(carbonated hydroxyapatite).
The entire process is called demineralization.
Should you get rid of the sugars, and are
the one and only person to follow your dentist’s
advice to brush and floss after every meal,
ions from your saliva will help with rebuilding
tooth enamel (remineralization).
When demineralization exceeds remineralization,
a cavity forms.
That process usually takes months to years.
When fluoride is placed on your teeth, it
combines in plaque fluid, along with the dissolved
hydroxyapatite found in your tooth veneer,
and will create a layer on your teeth called
fluoridated hydroxyapatite (FHA).
FHA limits the uptake of sugar by bacteria,
and reduces the amount of acid they produce,
preventing the corrosion of your enamel.
The fluoride will also help remineralize teeth
by attracting calcium.
The net result of both these actions reduces
demineralization while promoting remineralization,
and you get cavity-free teeth!
Since fluoride doesn’t necessarily cure
cavities, more specifically reduces the production
of them, it requires frequent application
throughout your life to achieve its protective
affects.
Adding it to the water you drink provides
a fantastic way to accomplish repeated exposure.
So, now that we know the proponents side of
the story, what are the drawbacks to taking
in fluoride and how much is too much in the
first place?
There are countless claims on the internet,
and in certain publications, citing studies
showing excessive fluoride will do everything
from lower your IQ, give you thyroid problems,
cause kidney issues, or even increase your
risk of cancer.
Fortunately, contrary to many somewhat suspect
interpretations of results of studies (where
present), to date, no study has definitively
shown any of this.
However, you shouldn’t take this to mean
that extremely excessive fluoride intake won’t
cause health problems; after all, even excessive
water intake can be deadly and, as a paramedic,
I’ve personally seen otherwise healthy individuals
die as a result of the side effects of drinking
too much water in a relatively short span.
Pretty much everything, including things your
body needs to function, is bad for you in
high enough doses.
However, with fluoride, at least to date,
no one has ever definitively proven the aforementioned
claims by many opponents of water fluoridation,
even at far higher regular doses of fluoride
than most of us imbibe.
That being said, there are two definitively
known complications from taking in too much
fluoride- Enamel fluorosis and skeletal fluorosis.
At fluoride levels of around 8mg/liter of
water taken in, combined with common dental
products, you can (potentially) get enamel
fluorosis.
Minor enamel fluorosis will result in horizontal
opaque striations on your tooth enamel that
can become white opaque patches.
More severe cases will cause changes to your
tooth color, like in the brown teeth Dr. McKay
noticed in his Colorado Springs patients.
While abnormally colored teeth is undesirable
for aesthetic reasons, functionally, enamel
fluorosis doesn’t appear to have any negative
health effects.
The pay-off, as Dr. McKay noted, would be
extra protection against cavities.
As to the second item there, the skeletal
problems associated with too much fluoride,
skeletal fluorosis, can be very debilitating.
Before you begin having symptoms, skeletal
fluorosis can be detected by x-ray showing
a slight increase in your bone mass.
That bone mass is 2-5 times higher than in
people who consume the recommended amount
of fluoride.
Once you do begin having symptoms, your condition
will come in 3 stages.
Stage 1 will result in occasional stiffness
and pain in your joints, and an abnormally
hard pelvis and vertebra called osteosclerosis.
Stage 2 and 3 can be very crippling, and results
in calcification of your ligaments, osteoporosis
of long bones, muscle wasting, and some neurological
defects associated with too much calcium in
your vertebra.
The amount of skeletal fluorosis is directly
related to the amount and duration of your
exposure to fluoride.
Now, if you’re thinking the prospects of
muscle wasting and painful joints aren’t
worth having a bit better dental health, don’t
worry.
Most people will need an intake of at the
extreme minimum 10mg/day for more than 10
years to produce even mild symptoms of this
conditions.
In fact, one study showed that even in communities
where people were getting 20mg per day, there
were no cases of skeletal fluorosis.
Crippling skeletal fluorosis is so rare that
only 5 cases have been reported in the last
35 years world-wide.
You actually need to take in so much fluoride
that one confirmed case had a 64-year-old
man ingesting 50mg/day for over 6 years, and
he still only had a mild case of the condition!
Thus, given the known risk/benefit analyses
of fluorinating water, food, toothpaste and
so on, you can see why so many governments
and health bodies are in favor of water fluoridation
to help ensure people get enough fluoride.
As those who neglect their dental hygiene
throughout their lives inevitably discover
as the decades pass- poor dental health is
a major literal and figurative pain once it
catches up to you, not to mention insanely
expensive.
So anything that increases the odds of teeth
staying “healthy” and functional into
our twilight years is often going to be a
good thing.
However, while many opponents of water fluoridation’s
reasons for opposing it may not be valid based
on the current state of research on the subject,
they may have a point on advocating getting
rid of it.
In short, while you’re unlikely to suffer
any negative side effects from it, water fluoridation
simply might not be necessary anymore in many
parts of the world.
You see, prior to the 1960s when water fluoridation
was becoming more popular, a person’s diet
was the only significant source of fluoride.
Today, however, fluoride is consumed in countless
common dental products, among other things,
so water fluoridation isn’t typically needed
anymore to achieve the recommended daily amounts.
On that note, there are a few studies showing
there is an increase in the rates of enamel
fluorosis in children in areas where there
is optimally fluoridated water, indicating
that these children are getting too much relative
to their mass.
And while, as noted, enamel fluorosis isn’t
exactly a cause for concern, other than potential
negatives on the aesthetics’ side of things,
it is a clear indicator that the water fluoridation
for these kids just isn’t necessary at all.
When it comes to water fluoridation today,
the most damning evidence against it comes
from a Cochran review performed in 2015.
They looked at 20 studies on the effects of
fluoridated water on tooth decay and 135 studies
on dental fluorosis.
While they did find that overall water fluoridation
is effective at reducing levels of tooth decay
by 35% among children, importantly, the results
were based on old studies that, as noted,
may not be applicable today.
They state;
The available data come predominantly from
studies conducted prior to 1975…Our confidence
in the size of the effect estimates is limited
by the observational nature of the study designs,
the high risk of bias within the studies and,
importantly, the applicability of the evidence
to current lifestyles (the use of fluoride
in toothpaste)…There is insufficient evidence
to determine whether water fluoridation results
in a change in disparities in caries levels
across SES (socioeconomic status).
We did not identify any evidence, meeting
the reviews inclusion criteria, to determine
the effectiveness of water fluoridation for
preventing caries in adults.
So, to sum up, in 1945 when cities began fluorinating
water, it appears there was definitely an
overall benefit to the public.
Currently, with the advent of modern dentistry
and fluoride put in many products used regularly
by most anyway, like toothepaste, the question
of whether governments should continue water
fluoridation is a good one.
At least as far as I could find, there currently
aren’t any studies that analyze cavity rates
while accounting for exposure to all major
sources of fluoride in modern times.
Until that happens, as with anything that
affects public policy, it appears the benefit
to the majority will always outweigh the potential
problems associated with the minority, especially
when those potential problems are either relatively
benign or extremely rare.
With fluoridation of water, the potential
problems appear to be so minor or few and
far between, and continuing the practice so
cheap, that I would assume it will be a long
time before you see municipalities ceasing
the practice.